[Music]
this is my favorite all right the
distraction of happiness oh yeah you
like that yes yeah so so the really what
you're talking about here and i'll just
read it here when when we try to satisfy
the pursuit of happiness in the pursuit
of self we always fall short of the
truest most lasting forms of happiness
it's that pursuit of happiness that
makes us unhappy yeah
uh it's the pursuit
it is the pursuit of happiness in
selfish pursuits
that makes us unhappy would be is how i
would define it um
i don't think there's anything wrong
with the pursuit of happiness i think we
all want to live a life that we're
satisfied with and
um
find meaning and joy in the the problem
is that we're
chasing it in a lot of the wrong places
and we confuse the pursuit of self and
the pursuit of happiness and we think
they're the same
um but in reality it's when we
serve others when we take care of others
when we live for others when we live
selfless lives that we get to the end of
our lives most satisfied with it yeah
and isn't it true that there's a flip
side of that we can also get addicted or
distracted by the need to contribute
feeling as though we need to always give
give give give
without making sure that we are taking
care of ourselves as well so there's i
wouldn't call it a balance but there's
like this sort of
homeostasis of contribution in a way
so much of the book is about
what is motivating us to do the things
that we do like do we do the things that
we do
to make more money do we do the things
that we do so that um
we selfish like we're taking care of
ourselves like if if this is the goal
uh then we get distracted i think from
from things that actually matter in the
long run um and so as i mentioned in the
book i mean the what's the saying uh
you can't pour from an empty cup like
like there's a space for
caring for ourselves and taking good
care of ourselves and not running on
empty ourselves but is the goal of that
so i can just pour into the biggest cup
that i can possibly have or is the goal
of investing into myself so that i can
invest my life into others i think that
that's the point i try to make yeah and
which you're trying to make too
maybe not i think
i think the biggest distraction in our
society might be
that mixed with this next one so the
happiness piece plus the distraction of
money which is the fourth distraction
yeah that's a good one huh you have a
really interesting take in the book that
not a lot of people talk about is
maybe you have enough money already oh
boy
as soon as you say that it's like i
don't like that here comes the point of
privilege but then you start going into
the stats and it's like oh 43 of people
live off of 550 or less a day
so you're already in the top half of the
world roughly yeah um and probably if
you're living in america you know we
have people in
190 countries who listen but if you're
if you're living in america you're
probably in the top ten percent
and so even when ryan and i grew up
really poor it's perspectival right we
grew up poor for america yeah yeah but
poor in america is not poor in
bangladesh no we were the fattest kids
in the fifth grade yeah and we were poor
but we sure got our meals
we sure were able to eat yeah yeah we
were malnourished in a different way
yeah uh in terms of nutrition but also
in terms of like support and community
etc so there's different types of
malnourishment you want to talk a bit
about money
so this is probably the
second thought that came after i started
minimizing possessions
so if i was gonna own less stuff and be
content to own less stuff
then what role is money supposed to play
in my life
like if the if if the goal isn't to have
more money to buy more stuff then what's
the point of money
also i started to realize that i could
live on a lot less money than i thought
i needed to get by
so um it's like 72 percent of americans
have financial related stress
and it's just a fascinating stat to me
considering we are the wealthiest
country in the history of the world
and still over seven out of every ten of
us are worried about like stressed about
money it's not because we don't have
enough money like there are some people
who don't have enough money but
the people who
don't have enough money are a far
smaller percentage of people than think
they are i phrase that right um that
made sense and so why are we so stressed
about money and i i've just come to the
realization that we keep looking for
money to provide something that it's
never going to provide for us we want
money to provide happiness and we want
money to provide security and it doesn't
provide either of those things at least
a little bit at the beginning and then
above and beyond that uh not much longer
and so we think if i have that much
money if i make that much money i'll
finally be happy and i'll finally feel
secure and we get to that much money
and we don't feel any happier and we
don't feel any secure we're just as
worried about money as we were with our
last paycheck before
and the thinking isn't
maybe maybe money isn't going to provide
those things the thinking is oh i just
had the wrong number in mind and
actually i need this much money to feel
happy and secure and we get in this
endless chase
of needing and wanting more and more
money all the time when in reality
um a lot of people already have enough
there's enough coming in um and there
are
other places to find happiness and
security yeah i remember eighty eighty
percent of people i'm sorry no worries i
shouldn't be cutting off on your podcast
man cut me off
in our survey 80 percent of people said
they'll be happier if they had more
money
ooh and uh i think that's uh
um
interesting yeah it's probably not zero
percent it's also probably not eighty
percent i mean depending on what that
money is going to provide but i remember
when i was in the corporate world i had
this million dollar number in my mind if
i could just make a million bucks i'll
be set i could like you know
maybe retire early you know i had all
these you know stories i was telling
myself about a million dollars and then
when it came time to start thinking
about walking away from my job
i actually sat down and did the numbers
i put a budget together and as i was
putting it together i was just shocked
at how
i didn't need a million dollars to
survive i mean that that first year we
got laid off i think josh and i made
like 22 000 bucks or something i mean it
was hardly anything
and that was one of the most stress-free
years of my life
yeah
you identified what enough was for you
and it's also worth noting that enough
changes in time you have a wife and a
daughter now so my enough when i started
minimalism is different now
and it doesn't mean there's going to be
a fixed number especially with inflation
and all these other things right that
million dollars by a parking spot in l.a
oh my god
and so like
it's
depending on where you live what your
needs are what the times are but even
those things the acquisition of those
things aren't necessarily going to make
you happier they won't make you more
secure they might make you slightly more
comfortable but that comfort
just ups your threshold for the desire
for more and more and more comfort we
can bubble wrap our world but it doesn't
mean that we're going to be happier or
more secure yeah man the next one is the
distraction of
possessions oh which we've never talked
about so
uh no we'll we'll skip that one because
we'll be talking more about that
especially on the minimal episode but uh
the sixth distraction
and this is one
that um i think a lot of us don't
realize
we have and it's the distraction of
applause
yeah another way to say that might be
validation
needing to be accepted nothing wrong
with being accepted it feels wonderful
but as soon as we feel as though i must
have your applause your adulation your
veneration
now
i've put myself in a little prison
yeah agreed agreed um
or not even just that i need it but i
i want it so much that i begin
living my life
for that applause for that appreciation
um i mean the reality is some of the
most important things that we do in life
will never
get noticed will never be appreciated
um
man i think of all the
i mean i think of all the the mothers
out there who are who are raising their
children and are never going to
be applauded for investing their lives
into their kids and yet
i mean probably the most important job
in in all of society is raising healthy
moral
children you know they contribute to
society and um so
yeah there's some jobs that you know
require
applause and require attention and
there's some that naturally attract it
more than others and there's some
personality types that attract it more
than others but when we fall into that
distraction of living my life
for the applause of others then i think
is where we start to get
um
uh
detracted or distracted i think from uh
some of the most important things that
we can and should be doing with our
lives yeah
and we all desire to some extent right i
mean i want to be liked i love being
liked but it's when you need to be like
when you start living to be liked and i
think what you know with everything
we're talking about like the money for
example this isn't about making anyone
feel guilty for needing some money or
for desiring some applause it's really
about
like is that your main focus if these
things become your main focus and that's
what drives you
it's probably going to lead you
somewhere uh that you didn't want to go
yeah yeah
man you should have wrote the book
did i get that sentence in there did i
get anything close to that sentence in
the book because you nailed it thanks
man thanks thanks for uh applauding me
yeah you guys make your appearance in
that chapter
well let's let's talk about the next one
that was most surprising to me oh
beautiful all right good did you enjoy
this stand-alone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
slash the minimalists or click the link
in the description your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel 100
percent advertisement free